now to the fight against the coronavirus
the us has finally reached president
biden's original vast
vaccination goal 70 percent of american
adults have now been at least
partially vaccinated but it's not a time
for celebration especially in areas
where
many people still refuse to get the
shots one of those states
is louisiana take a listen to dr
catherine o'neal she is the chief
medical officer
at the largest hospital in the state
here she is talking about the state's
vaccination effort and it's not
helping enough because it's not
happening fast
enough and when you come inside our
walls
it is quite obvious to you that these
are
the darkest days of this pandemic she
went on to say at her hospital in baton
rouge they are
out of beds 17 states still have
vaccination rates
under 50 percent that includes louisiana
and missouri
and that is where we find maria
villarreal this morning maria good
morning
well good morning david the show me
state has seen enough
here at cox health in springfield health
care workers tell me they are
struggling to keep up with the highest
number of covett patients they have seen
since the start of the pandemic
right now administrators have brought in
a new morgue and they are beefing up
they are doubling their oxygen reserves
all in anticipation of a rise in cases
and unfortunately a rise in deaths
four weeks ago i would have told you i'm
not sure we can take care of 100
patients and now we're 187.
steve edwards president and ceo of cox
health
says some people unwilling to get the
vaccine are putting hospitals on their
heels
and in some cases are even blaming
health care workers
under the notion that hospitals are
profiting from the pandemic
it's disappointing right i liken it to
people returning from war and someone
spitting in their eye that's how some of
our nurses feel
one of our nurses said that that's
literally happened to her springfield
missouri has seen a dramatic rise in
covet patients
with average daily cases more than
doubling in less than a month
with the vaccination rate hovering just
above 40 percent
springfield's public schools are now
requiring all students and staff
wear masks when school starts up again
in three weeks
katie towns is the director of greene
county health department
this time around the disease has
affected those who
are unvaccinated which has made this
disease really translate into a younger
demographic
so i mean like immunocompromised college
freshman jack klinkenbeard
who was the first of his high school
classmates to be diagnosed with covid
last july during his senior year
and also one of the first to get
vaccinated in early february
how i saw it was if i get it then
i can do i can go back to normal things
but if i don't
imagine to i'm still back to where we
started and not progressing forward
but not everyone in jack's family feels
that way
his mom america has been fighting
vaccine hesitancy
in her own home for months it split our
family i have one son that will not get
vaccinated and i hope he's watching
i don't know what the split is it seems
to me like it's there's no
in between you're either absolutely or
absolutely not
and i've yet to figure out what the
absolutely not
is about we are seeing that kind of
split all over the country right now
here in missouri if health officials are
doing all they can to combat
that misinformation they are trying to
flood social media and also work with
local partners to really just get the
information out
they are also beefing up their
incentives and one of the incentives
is actually a state-funded raffle where
up to 900 people
can win ten thousand dollars in cash or
a ten thousand dollar scholarship and
whatever they are doing here in missouri
it has seemed to work or the power of
mom because
last night we got a text message from
america she says her last hold out son
has decided to get vaccinated and he's
promised to do it
today anthony that's some good news
maria thank you